es ist eine wirklich düstere prognose
die an kanadisches forschungsteam in
einer aktuellen studie zeichnet erstmals
überhaupt haben forschende weltweit eine
klima prognose aufgestellt die sehr weit
in die zukunft blickt ins jahr 2500 wird
die erde uns menschen bis dahin
überhaupt noch unsere heimat bieten und
wenn ja wie wird unser leben dann
aussehen klicks on science and future
gibt es drei mal pro woche spannender
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen wie sieht unsere
welt in der zukunft aus und wie lange
werden wir menschen überhaupt noch auf
unserem heimatplaneten der erde leben
können gefahren und risiken gibt es
zuhauf stephen hawking hatte immer
wieder gewarnt dass die menschheit sich
lieber still verhalten sollte denn
ansonsten könnten außerirdische wesen
auf uns aufmerksam werden und zur gefahr
werden tesla chef elon musk warnt
dagegen vor einem asteroideneinschlag
dem wir dann im fall der fälle schutzlos
ausgeliefert werden tatsächlich ist es
nicht die frage ob ein gigantischer
asteroid irgendwann mit der erde
kollidieren wird sondern wann die zeit
spielt also gegen uns der asteroid
apophis könnte die erde in sieben jahren
2029 nur knapp verfehlen aber auch auf
der erde selbst lauern gefahren und zwar
direkt unter der erde supervulkan können
jederzeit verheerende katastrophen mit
globalen folgen auslösen eine neue
studie kam vor einigen monaten zu
alarmierenden ergebnissen
demnach können super vulkane nach einem
ausbruch noch jahrtausende gefährlich
und aktiv bleiben und trotz intensiver
forschung sind wir noch immer nicht in
der lage solche mega eruption vorher zu
sagen wir haben gerade darüber berichtet
hier der link unter mir fest steht
jedenfalls dass forschungsteams weltweit
an ideen tüfteln den menschen eine neue
heimat zu schaffen dabei im visier der
mars den visiten könnten um so das
überleben der menschen zu sichern und
auch der klimawandel der bereits jetzt
spürbare auswirkungen auf das leben der
menschen hat ist eine gefahr für die
menschheit er raubt uns die arbeit ganze
landstriche und existenzen doch welche
auswirkungen hat die klimakrise
langfristig auf unseren heimat daneben
die erde bislang hatten fachleute immer
nur eine prognose bis zum jahr 2100
gewagt jetzt aber haben forschende
weiter in die zukunft geblickt bis ins
jahr 2005 100 und die prognose ist mehr
als düster wie wird unser planet also in
480 jahren aussehen können wir menschen
ihn weiterhin bewohnen die antworten auf
diese spannenden fragen und noch viel
mehr gibt es jetzt hier bei klicks um
salz in future schon jetzt ist die
klimakrise für jeden einzelnen und jede
einzelne von uns spürbar klar ist
mittlerweile allen dass wir uns mit
wetterextremen wie starke regen hitze
und dürren arrangieren müssen es gibt
ernteausfälle die meeresspiegel steigen
invasive arten breiten sich aus ebenso
wie krankheitserreger fachleute weltweit
sprechen mittlerweile von einer zitat
klima eskalation vor einigen wochen
brachte eine studie der
weltwetterorganisation wmo neue zahlen
und fakten auf den tisch demnach ist die
zahl der wetter- oder klimabedingten
katastrophen seit dem jahr 1970 deutlich
gestiegen zwischen 2000 und 2009 waren
es sogar fünf mal so viele wie in den
70er jahren wie die
weltwetterorganisation in dem neuen
bericht waren überschwemmungen und
stürme bilden fast 80 prozent dieser
katastrophen ereignisse und solche
naturkatastrophen kosten nicht nur viel
geld sondern auch unzählige
menschenleben und das nicht mehr nur in
fernen ländern sondern auch bei uns
direkt vor unserer haustür wie zb im
aartal im letzten jahr während die
menschen weltweit die auswirkungen der
klimatischen bedingungen zu spüren
bekommen haben die staats und
regierungschefs im dezember letzten
jahres in glasgow über strengere
klimaschutz regeln debattiert dieser
un-gipfel kopf 26 hat entscheidende
fortschritte gebracht aber werden sie
reichen von manchen aktivistinnen und
aktivisten aber auch forschungsteams
weltweit wurde der gipfel als zitat
letzte chance gesehen es herrscht
alarmstufe rot und große player wie etwa
die präsidenten chinas russlands und
brasiliens haben die konferenz
geschwänzt und auch in den usa gibt es
weiter widerstand die befürchtung sind
also berechtigt dass das 2015 in paris
vereinbarte ziel nicht erreicht werden
kann demnach wollte man die erderwärmung
im vergleich zur vorindustriellen zeit
auf 1,5 art begrenzen aber das langsame
vorankommen könnte und teuer zu stehen
kommen das zeigt jetzt eine aktuelle
studie aus kanada das forschungsteam hat
zum ersten mal überhaupt gewagt eine
klima prognose aufzustellen die über das
jahr 2100 hinausreicht das jahr 2100
galt lange zeit als ausreichend ferner
zeithorizont doch mittlerweile sind wir
von dieser marke nicht einmal mehr 80
jahre entfernt zahlreiche menschen die
heutzutage geboren wurden werden auch
das jahr 2100 noch erleben zudem haben
viele studien in der vergangenheit sehr
deutlich gemacht dass viele
veränderungen zwar jetzt bereits
ausgelöst wurden deren auswirkungen
werden sich aber wohl erst mit
verzögerung zeigen was also droht uns
wenn wir das 1,5 grad oder auch das
nicht so strenge zwei grad ziel nicht
schaffen die aktuellen ergebnisse der
fachleute sind erschreckten studien aus
der früheren vergangenheit hatten
bereits nahegelegt dass das klimasystem
sehr träge ist demnach könnte ein
sofortiger stopp der co2 emissionen den
treibhauseffekt zwar messbar senken aber
das möglicherweise achtung erst
jahrzehnte später weitere jahrhunderte
lang könnten die temperaturen also
selbst dann noch hoch bleiben die ozeane
sich immer weiter erwärmen die
meeresspiegel ansteigen und die
eiskappen weiter schmelzen für ihre
aktuelle analyse hatten die forschenden
eine version des britischen atmosphäre
ozean modells hat cm3 genutzt dieses
beinhaltet auch die entwicklung der
landfläche und vegetation dazu heißt es
von den klimaforscherin und forschern
aus kanada
das hat cm3 ist in bezug auf die
reaktion des klimas auf externe
einflüsse repräsentativ aber benötigt
weniger computerleistung als neuere
modelle so wurde es also möglich
prognosen zu verlängern und das über
einen langen zeitraum hinweg diese
simulation ließen die fachleute dann in
drei gängigen klimaszenarien durchlaufen
bei dem klima szenario rcp 2.6 geht man
von einem sehr schnellen und effektiven
klimaschutz aus mit dem das zwei grad
ziel erreicht wird das szenario rzb 4.5
beinhaltet eine erwärmung von 2,6 grad
also einem mittleren klimaschutz auf
einen fast ungebremsten co2 ausstoß bis
zum jahr 2100 und einem eher schwachen
klimaschutz basiert dagegen das thema
szenario erp 6.0 die forschenden hatten
vor allem die folgenden fragen im visier
wie werden sich die temperaturen und die
vegetation verändern und mit welchen
folgen muss bezüglich der landwirtschaft
berechnet werden die neue studie zeigt
auf dass die antworten auf all diese
fragen dramatisch sind das
forschungsteam schreibt unter anderem
dass uns viele gebiete auf der erde im
jahr 2500 als lebensraum verloren gehen
unsere projektionen für die welt
jenseits des jahres 2001 unser zeigen
dass sich ohne schnelle und signifikante
reduktion der treibhausgasemissionen
weite gebiete der erde so verändert
werden dass sie für eine menschliche
besiedlung nicht mehr geeignet die zeit
läuft also und zwar gegen uns um solch
eine entwicklung noch zu verhindern
bleibt kaum noch gelegenheit und auch in
den anderen regionen dieser erde wird
der mensch als der große verlierer
darstellen auf einen großteil der
bevölkerung wird ein enormer hitze
stress zu kommen das klima auf der erde
wird für die menschen kaum erträglich
sein der aufenthalt im freien wird
möglicherweise noch mit einer speziellen
schutzausrüstung möglich sein die hitze
zonen werden sich in den kommenden
jahren bis in die gemäßigten breiten
ausdehnen doch nicht nur das zudem wird
auch die dauer der heißen phasen zu
nehmen tausende hitze tote gibt es ja
bereits jetzt pro jahr in indien die
sommertemperaturen dort könnten sich
allerdings noch einmal um vier grad
erhöhen dazu dann verstärkter starkregen
durch einen intensiven monsun die
landwirtschaft kann dann nicht mehr
durch menschen betrieben werden dazu
heißt es in der studie der
landwirtschaftliche freilandanbau würde
dann vorliegen von auto sie hätten
robotern übernommen doch dadurch ist
eines der hauptprobleme noch lange nicht
gelöst denn fakt ist diese klimatischen
veränderungen lassen die anbaugebiete
für grundnahrungsmittel schrumpfen um
bis zu 18 prozent könnten die flächen
für die zehn wichtigsten
grundnahrungsmittel schrumpfen wie die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
waren kartoffeln
süßkartoffeln weizen mais reis
sojabohnen und hirse werden knapp die
aktuelle analyse aber macht auch
hoffnung denn wenn wir es schaffen
würden dem klimawandel auf unter zwei
grad erwärmung zu begrenzen sehe das
bild schon weniger dramatisch aus die
anbaugebiete für die nutzpflanzen der
gemäßigten breiten würden dann nur um
2,9 prozent und für die tropischen
grundnahrungsmittel würden sie sogar um
2,9 prozent gewachsen ein weiteres
beispiel das zum nachdenken anregt ist
der amazonas regenwald nach ansicht der
kanadischen forscher könnte sich dieses
gebiet bis 2500 sogar zu einer steppe
oder wüste verwandeln dazu heißt es in
der studie heute beherbergt er ein
drittel der bekannten spezies und
absorbiert rund sieben prozent der
anthropogenen co2 emission
klimabedingungen waldsterben und dessen
positive rückkopplung werden den größten
teil des amazonasbeckens in eine karge
landschaft verwandeln menschliche
präsenz und infrastrukturen gäbe es dort
angesichts der hohen temperaturen und
trockenheit dann kaum noch der appell
der experte den experten ist deutlich
handeln müssen wir uns zwar jetzt sofort
wir müssen daran denken in welcher welt
unsere kinder und enkel künftig leben
sollen und was wir jetzt tun können um
die erde auch für sie lebensfreundlich
zu erhalten viele folgen des
klimawandels sind bisher nicht bedacht
worden und machen die folgen zum teil
noch dramatischer nasa mond löst bald
katastrophen auf der erde aus
küstenstädte werden durch den
klimawandel und veränderungen in der
mondumlaufbahn schon in wenigen jahren
ganz konkret durch flutkatastrophe
bedroht mehr dazu gibt es in dem video
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran